you believe that at this point you are
feeling the ripple effects from slavery
in the history of the United States and
that you face systemic discrimination I
think there are definitely been times in
my life
in places that I've been where I have
felt the effects it's time for the
newest change my mind a series where we
rationalize our positions on usually
controversial topics for this
installment we decided to take on a
subject which seems to be all over the
news lately the United States is often
called the great melting pot but it's a
country that struggled with race
relations throughout its history and
still does today does America have a
race problem all the evidence says yes
it's a history of oppression because of
the raw ugly racism and
ethno-nationalism of our president but
what do you think is the United States
of America as of 2020 is the
systemically racist country let me know
in the comments below and talk amongst
yourselves and remember if you want
these videos this series to continue
please do consider joining Mudd Club up
at lot of credit comment / Mudd Club you
get this wonderful hand etched
hand-painted mug as well as a Daily Show
that has not fully broadcast on YouTube
at $69 annually for students veterans
active military I really appreciate the
support
all right on with the show meet Kendall
what's a name sir I'm Kendall Cole
Kendall nice to meet Jeannie wear mask
okay okay my name's Steven connect this
Punk yeah I'm sorry I'll do the
handshake are we good with a handshake
all right well I never did you just call
on that did you have your mom that's it
I plead the fifth all right you guys
good
okay that yeah sorry about that okay
sorry let me get your name one more time
key spelling out Kendall que en da ll da
Cole that's my Twitter handle and I
gotta get the plug-in okay well careful
what you wish for because the people on
the Twitter not always that nice to me
yeah and I mean celebrities if they come
into the show I'm just thinking don't
take a picture with me unless you want
to get a bunch of crap it happens no not
to this level so I just say to say you
know her eyes I think the Internet is
just a place that kind of breeds hate
and when people have anonymity they'll
say whatever they want to say right well
I think we agree on that so that leads
me into kind of I know how familiar you
are if at all to change our mind concept
I've seen all to change my mind okay yes
I know you do other content I haven't
watched much of that but well I like the
change my mind sockets it's interesting
so you're familiar with the fact that
it's sometimes you will come up and they
get very angry
yeah now is the time it's meant to be a
dialogue of conversations particularly
bout controversial issues because those
are the issues that we typically avoid
yeah those are the interesting
conversation seem right
next one is gonna be all public transit
should be firebombed you know I would
agree if it wasn't for the fact that
they pay my dad's paychecks okay all
right sorry no your dad's and then we'll
send antov over the rest of the book so
uh this one is a little bit different we
were just talking about Cove it I know
you wanted to talk about that maybe we
can revisit that afterward um I think
something that kind of ties in right now
if Cole did being racist okay no no not
Cove it being racist but me being how to
know you're a racist
maybe maybe a little bit Jesus I think
we're all of it okay let me just I don't
believe that that's not necessary and
have a new cue reference but I do not
believe that the United States today in
2020 is a racist country there's no
systemic racism in the United States and
I think is Polly important to talk about
when you have these riots going on where
people are making demands that aren't
really numerable aren't really
quantifiable it's just sort of us
general and I understand malaise with
the system so I don't believe the United
States is a racist country if you
disagreed even more than walking
achievements so it was interesting to me
at the beginning you said you don't
think it's a racist country today do you
think that at some point it was a racist
country yes okay so that's why I'm not
saying that the United States was never
racist country yeah I think slavery was
a horrible evil yes and I think it was
horrible that it took us to get to the
60s for the Civil Rights Act I'm not at
all here to argue that the United States
was never a racist nation every single
nation since the really the dawn of
civilization has practiced slavery one
form or another still practiced across
the globe
thank God we abolished yeah so it's my
question up front for you is at what
point did we stop being racist was it
was when the Emancipation Proclamation
was signed or when you know I wish day
after the after the Civil Rights Act so
the day of the day that everyone was
giving no I mean systemically yeah now
doesn't mean that there weren't
individual races yeah and particularly
when I'm talking about 2020 because
mostly people out there protesting when
we're not the people who were around
during the Civil Rights area we have a
lot of young Americans I have never
suffered the hands of systemic
oppression okay um your sign
specifically you're talking about
systemic oppression yes okay not racist
individuals are plenty racist
individuals and you can find those
black/white yeah yeah we just had a
deadline right there I cost my friend
there who's a biracial tell him that he
was white me so that sounds kind of
racist I think I got really mad and then
I said well I don't know argue brown or
you know he got mad at me so I'm just
using your same shading rules and he
said something about checking a white
box and I create all the tests so I
don't necessarily know what was going on
there but I'm not arguing that there are
not individual races but as a country
the United States not only do I believe
it's the best country in the world for
people of any races um
I agree there's no other best country in
the world yeah but I think the main
place where I disagree
perhaps not we don't have systemic
racism but I think that whenever you
think about racism you have to keep in
mind classism I think that systemically
there are a lot of systems that do
divide classes and keep lower classes to
suppress and because of our history
because of the way that black people and
many brown people were treated in the
past maybe are tied into lower classes
and you have to keep in mind that we're
talking about racism often times people
actually mean classism the two are very
closely intertwined just when you look
at the numbers how it is let me ask you
kind of to define classism and how you
think that there's systemic oppression
through the form of classism maybe we'll
find I think we probably find some
common ground and some areas very
disagree yeah um just if you look at job
opportunities you know oftentimes people
say go ahead get a four-year degree
that's gonna give you more job
opportunities but for people who are
completely broke you know oftentimes
four-year degrees are not opportunities
that they have because they can't take
go into that financial deficit and they
don't have the time
to be able to get those degrees and
things like that I think there are a
number of things that and I didn't come
here prepared today though no no that's
the boss I think it's gonna be will be
helpful as we talk so I can kind of
annuity that I applied to someone who's
poor who's white just as much as someone
who's boards black like the trailer park
kid from Arkansas is that just as much
of a disadvantage as for black Johnson
well I think that the poor trailer park
trash people in Arkansas and citrus I
did I'm not I'm not men see about words
I I'm concerned about the meaning behind
that is triggered by the message and
pronounced ingenuous I don't I don't
like it up truck I want to go back to
what you're saying yeah you think most
black people think the way you do
no absolutely not you think they are
offended by words I think most people in
general are offended by words cuz they
accept people that I've met most average
black Americans not those in the media
don't tend to be nearly as sensitive as
privileged white people
I've seen it both ways I don't think
there's a way you can generalize it okay
it's so you're dissing my cooking yes
yeah I think we all are I've got all
special little snowflakes okay so I'd
rather you not just because what happens
is let's say you know someone at Shake
Shack poisoned it
then I'll hook I work at in and out and
I'll still go we're gonna no idea well
then I have a beef with you because I
think you're already overhyped over
everything
so the trailer-trash huh that's true
okay that is true I think people just
like to feel like they're a part of the
secret menu so you said the white
trailer trash from Arkansas so going
back to classes and can't believe that
it would be the same disadvantage for
someone who was poor in a lower-class
trailer-trash white person from Arkansas
as what's a kid from inner-city South
Dallas Ori no no not quite because of
the stereotypes and the presumptions
that people carry you know I think that
when a white person walks into the
public people oftentimes they go in with
a more neutral idea of women could be
they have less assumptions or whatnot
just like okay look at look in this room
right now I'm the only black person
well you weren't there are other black
guys rule maybe thirty minutes ago okay
I'm very outnumbered I'm out ratioed
right now all right what can you say
something right there yeah because I
will tell you this there have been some
people who come up with in unsavory
characters and you would not be to some
now I will acknowledge us sometimes you
make assumptions when you see somebody
for example if I see a guy let Hells
Angels jacket they go oh let me be
careful
our fees you know we've got a teardrop
tattoo you would be someone here I would
think oh that's someone who dressed well
who's articulate has himself to guess
well right now me you got shoes going on
your your idea barely knows which is
more than I can say for everyone here
some of these people look like they
should you know they're the hobos so I
don't necessarily think that at least in
my experience and with everyone I know
who works on my trend we do have black
people we do
Latinos um yeah it is I don't think that
people would necessarily look I think
some would I don't think it's
necessarily true I think it's a lot more
common than you might think read off
could be yeah I think it's just it's the
unfortunate truth of the world that we
live in and it's derivative of the world
that we came from yeah I don't
necessarily know that I would agree with
that for a few reasons like we kind of
mentioned for example let's use the
education example specific deputies have
going into college I think that actually
a young black man from South Dallas has
a great advantage over a young white
trailer-trash she's from Arkansas
Eminem Salem's Lot will go that way it's
specific and we're not generalizing
anybody it's a very specific person hey
I'm all right because how are you yeah
oh where you from Detroit Michigan
Detroit Mount Pleasant or something
Detroit area I don't remember I moved
here I look for I don't really know I
remember what I hear you know there are
far more scholarships available to black
Americans and black Americans are
accepted at the universities with
significantly lower test scores than
white Americans or Asian Americans so I
do think that there have been some
attempts to right wrongs of the past
which actually haven't yielded good
results that yielded worst results and
applications and enrollments and
graduations and what's interesting is
when you look at the classism first off
we have more class mobility here in the
United States than anywhere else
certainly than can define class mobility
for me meaning there are more people in
the United States who end up in the top
30% of income and anywhere else in the
world at some point their life are in
the top 10% including people go from the
top 10 up from the bottom 10 or the
bottom 30 of the top 30 atop there's
more class mobility here in the United
States more ability to rise out of
poverty into upper-middle class than
anywhere else he taught us
just curious I'm gonna look it up out
for is ready get those number actually I
can show them to you here yeah I'd like
to yeah definitely the lab um and it's
even a saying where you take people
where they might have a higher overall
quality of living like Sweden or Denmark
you take Swedes ordains and you bring
the United States and they have a higher
class mobility and higher quality of
living here in the United States because
I think we've acknowledged at different
countries of different cultures and
sometimes they're more studious and
there are cultures that are more
industrious but when you transplant any
culture in the United States
I shouldn't say any but all the stats
that we have available to us the best
parts of their cultures they bring
actually art accentuate and we see more
of them yeah I also think it's kind of
interesting well you say transplant in
the United States can't even more
specific on the areas I think why does
she's like Sweden and Denmark as an
example but we're in the United States
when they've been transplanted to has
anywhere anywhere United States I doubt
many of them are going you know to the
middle of Mississippi right but I think
that's part of the issue when you look
at rural areas when you look at ghettos
where a lot of these lower-income people
are where a lot of black people are
oftentimes and we get more so black
people oftentimes it's it's
statistically when you look at they're
all right
a portion of this society you know I
know there there are more white people
on welfare than black people there are
more white people in the United States
exactly yeah well that's something for
the ratio yeah I'm talking about a
population ratio yes capital you do have
more black people who are poor than well
yeah and I 80 percent oftentimes I mean
why do you think that is
mainly because of the history of the
United States the discrimination that
has happened in the past the
disadvantage that we were in in the past
you know we started so far behind in
this race like there's only so far that
as a collective we're gonna be now so
let me ask you this yeah someone how old
are you I'm 19 19 19 and a how you
believe that let's say a 19 year old
yourself yeah you seem like a pretty
articulate guy you go to school I think
you probably do okay you seem like a
pretty sure yeah you believe that at
this point you are feeling the ripple
effects
slavery in the history of the United
States and that you face systemic
discrimination I think there are
definitely been times in my life in
places that I've been where I have felt
the effects I think overall I grew up in
a very privileged family my parents they
make good money yeah parents yeah
nice other that's also far bigger than
the other statistic mm-hm yeah because
when you take that something that I
think is important I mean we could find
common ground when you take upper middle
class white kids or black kids they
perform typically the same when you take
lower class white kids or black kids
they often form the same when you take
any class kids without a dad they
perform very poorly by all metrics of a
almost matter of fact if you want to
avoid being in poverty there are three
things that you can do it's very simple
go to school don't commit a crime wait
till you're ready to have kids right so
I want to hear your your opinion on this
why do you think that oftentimes
more black children have to grow up in
one household
can I speak freely without being accused
of race yeah yeah yeah absolutely I
think it goes back to it goes back to
the welfare reform n it goes back to the
model Cities program it goes back to a
welfare state created that
disincentivizes people from staying
mimic there's a financial incentive
right now to not be married so that is
there why is it only happening to black
families because there's a higher
percentage of black families who use
well further than my families and why is
that because well at a certain point
that you'd have to end that cycle there
is a responsibility your parents chose
to stay together right that cycle can
only be broken through personal
responses you far away from that sure
why are more black families on welfare
but why are why were more black families
not getting divorced why do they have
stronger family households before the
modern welfare state in other words
blacks had a lower divorce rate we get
it careful there's a lot of connotations
there sure they had stronger family
units before the modern well first day
at strong fit now that was also sold to
them from the Democratic Party it was
sold to them as something that was owed
to them through reparations right this
was a big part of the targeted black
areas and encouraged them to get on
welfare and then through that point
continuing through that end they then
created financial incentives to not be
married then at a certain point I do
believe when all rights are equal since
the 1960s as far as the right to vote
the right to over talk about the right
to own property redlining has been
stopped and there are systemic
advantages afforded to minorities not
afforded to white people there does have
to be considering that we know how
beneficial and how much of a privilege
there's no greater privilege privilege
and being raised in a household with a
mother and father that some personal
responsibility does need to come into
account that's someone today who chooses
to walk out in their life does nothing
to do with the Emancipation Proclamation
what do you think the solution is what
do you think the endgame is it's very
tough to propose a solution because the
solution can only come from the ground
up through family units through strong
family is through moral character and
teaching people to stay with their kids
because like I said I think if we
educate young people white and black
listen be responsible don't commit
crimes graduate school wait till you're
married to have kids yeah then that will
change jenner that will generational
change in other words statistically I
think it's a 97% chance that you are
above at least middle class if you do
those things it's not really rocket
science and by the way that doesn't
necessarily mean that you need a higher
education degree yeah and no one talks
about it but and unfortunately unlike
our conversation here which I think it's
been pretty pretty fruitful you know
often if white people say that they're
accused of being a racist yeah well
before we stray too far away from that
we agree on that that that's something
that's been sort of tossed by the
wayside not been given the importance
that it needs for all families staying
together and raising someone a nuclear
family yeah overall yeah and it sports
cars means small pieces yeah if you're
driving like that it's okay we don't
judge it's not the size of the boat
motion of the ocean ship not true
going back to education I think primary
and secondary education is also a very
big issue people who grow up in less
fortunate areas people grow up in
ghettos oftentimes they don't get the
best primary education and you're saying
that the way to fix the nuclear family
is to further educate these people right
Wow no no no I didn't said I said we
need to have a nuclear family I have to
fix there is no nuclear family in the
black community a lot of time maybe I
misheard you but a few moments ago I I
said that what I courage in nuclear
family that means a mother father and
children other words time you use the
word education earlier so that's educate
young people yeah yeah yeah yeah but
don't necessarily mean that that comes
to school ah so we need to have farm
people yeah I need to go from school I
think it needs to come from leaders from
both communities and let me ask you this
how much have you learned in school
versus how much have you learned from
people you respect your books that you
read on your own or authoritative
figures far more from the latter me too
yeah and so I think that it's
responsibility for people to step up in
positions of power Authority who can
inform that's what I'm doing but I also
think that's a learned skill I think we
should teach people how did you learn
for themselves okay and I think that we
can teach that in our school swimmers
good yeah so let me ask you this and I
agree I think that schooling is
important I come from a place like I was
raised in Canada yeah born in Detroit
raised in Canada and they do have a much
better public education system because
you can go to pretty much any school you
want as long as you want to drive or
take a bus we call school choice here
and a lot of people say it's racist in
Canada system yeah if you take a bus
fine so what do you believe the problem
is in primary education or could I
definitely believe that our public
education system I think we're referring
to public education Yeah right
it's broken and needs improvement and
you think it's a big piece of the puzzle
definitely what do you believe is broken
there and how do you think we can maybe
fix it hard to say as someone who's not
an educator but I think that generally
schools that have better funding and
then have a staff that knows how to use
that funding are going to be better off
in the end so we need to have better
training for the faculty of the schools
so that they can know how to allocate
these funds properly how do you get
better training
by creating better programs and that
requires money yeah well I would agree
with you in the sense of habits that
people if you have to go to public
schools I think homeschooling is a big
option and we think of in nineteen
people can do it I think homeschool is
he has a very 50/50 with the results we
have quite a few homeschooled people in
the staff and I'm really yeah oh no your
mom must have been terrible not always a
Alibi mom I love you mom I was gonna get
that no he doesn't he said that you
place him in a problem I can beat him
with reads they that the thing is a lot
of the most expended school districts in
the country are underprivileged areas so
for example a of like Washington DC
you have Detroit these are areas
specifically where you're talking about
and they have higher per pupil spending
than most schools whenever it's served
more than many that's why earlier I said
I think we need to better allocate our
funds just more money isn't always the
answer right we need to know how to
spend the money I agree and that's
something that not so it sounds like
you'd be advocating for something like
school choice sounds Malia be advocating
for incentives for better teachers and
more punishments for PE teachers who are
bad and students definitely all things I
also agree with I'll probably work in
the police force I agree yeah I
completely agree I think for me I've
been saying for a long time we need to
reduce the power of teachers unions to
protect bad teachers to encourage good
teachers and the same exact thing with
the cops do we realize yes sir yeah so
it's not a money issue
it's a allocation of funds issue right
yeah but why do you think the allocation
of funds are so consistently bad in
black neighborhoods where a student seat
of the most like why do you think for
example a very poor the black Irish
collects neglect yeah and who's running
the school district I depends from area
to area Detroit it's all black its
people who should be serving their
community you know a student has more
chance of ending a student who enters
high school in Detroit has more chance
of ending up in prison than graduating
high school even though the per pupil
spending is almost fifteen thousand
dollars which is significantly above the
national average yeah and everyone who
sits on that board are people from
Detroit you can't find a white person
there and the reason I bring this up is
because
I think a lot of people have appreciate
your being straightforward about it
throwing money at the problem isn't fix
it well we continually throw more more
money at public schools and it's getting
worse
standardized testing scores are getting
worse forgiving electro and despite the
fact they have more money and resources
available to them than ever so my
question is why do you think that is and
how I think we agree on how to fix it a
big started looking at the unions and
creating incentivization for better
teachers but why do you think it's such
a problem in those communities neglect
and when I said neglect I think you
instantly assume that I meant just from
white people that's not what I meant
you know neglect can come in all forms
discrimination comes from all types of
people you know and a lot of times there
is a lot of self-hatred in the black
community as well really yeah
so that's interesting this is this is
honestly this is something that's a
little bit not black so I don't know
about self-hatred
I don't know comfortable that's because
we have social distancing okay this is
where you can just educate me a little
bit if you don't mind what do you know
about self-catered in the black
community can you describe what that is
yeah so a lot of times when you look at
the media there's one type of black
person that you see you know there's one
there's one thing that a lot of people
feel like they are assumed to be and
then they're told to be so I kind of
feeds into themself because I feel like
then and once they go into society this
is what people expect me to be so I
can't deviate too far from that because
they already have these preconceptions
yeah it's hard to change preconceptions
oftentimes especially like on a on a
first impression basis and you think
that that's these preconceptions of what
a black man should be is stronger than
typically what a white man should be
could you tell me maybe what it is you
feel is expected of someone like you as
a black man like what you mean say
preconceptions what do you what do you
mean you think they
that every black person is an athletic
guy who all they know how to do is play
sports and that's all that they want to
do yeah you're probably pretty athletic
right
no I'm fit but I'm not athletic I'm bad
at sports do you think maybe that they
exalt a certain group of I think was
recently sold that O'Brien said well
really CNN must have the right kind of
black people mm-hmm sir would you like
me definitely yeah yeah that's gotta be
tough
yeah because you know he's actually he
is biracial he's a quarter black quarter
black yeah and he's talked about that
because all of his relatives are black
and he'll get flack of his plentiful I
look he's kind of a nerd I mean look
he's in it like he has coheed and
cambria comic books he does a lot of the
props and make him say what are the ways
address right yeah I know you know I
mean he has some of his relatives I'm
like well you're not blocking he's like
well and my dad is actually just as
black as there's any toxin and I've got
to imagine listen this is something that
I don't really have to deal with as a
white first yeah you don't and that's
but it's not inflicted upon me from the
white community I mean we get black guys
who do like the comics like there was a
little white guy place you know they
think we all talked like that but it
doesn't really bother me Wade talks that
way so a lot of us do but this isn't
that you're saying that sometimes people
in the black community expect of you and
it's hard to not just the black made the
work I Marilyn yeah yeah that's pretty
tough you know a good example of that um
are you remember the 16 Olympics into
the Black Power simple I know the Black
Power someone well they did at the
Olympics there's been a lot of
documentaries about this me and I don't
maybe this might be interesting to you
and maybe not if you want to go you can
go I appreciate you taking the time
no I'm really enjoying the conversation
thank him to continue and I appreciate
it that you're sitting and I think well
I'm pretty good not neither one of us
have been interrupting but or yelling at
each other hitting each other but I yet
know people get there oh no I forgot on
don't you don't have to live up to that
stereotype just because people are
rioting I know a lot of intimate people
are rioting hey I didn't say I was
always gonna get aggressive you never
know that's true I've been known yeah so
was the guy named Sanchez and Smith they
at the 98 sorry 98 68 Olympics they held
up their fist at the podium yeah black
car right and there been a lot of
documentaries been a lot of subject or
this thing nothing is got
better because they works for you they
were rejected by America yeah and it's
been turned into a racial issue and the
reason I think this is important I'm
using a client example to make a point
is because that's a gross
misrepresentation of what happened at
those Olympics now they were supposed to
boycott the games they didn't boycott
the games and they came out with a team
and they forced a lot of white people
toward the back of the line when they
were marching out with the tour with
when they were marching out the Olympics
there's a lot of discrimination going
both ways but specifically at that point
against there's some white people on
scene were pretty upset but you know the
most popular athlete was to come out of
those Olympics no idea no George Foreman
mm-hmm never never heard of George
Foreman I've heard the name I don't
George Foreman grill okay the grill he
was a heavyweight champion that the
rumble in the jungle Holly George
Foreman yeah I said he was one of he was
one of the best heavyweights to vet
who's ever lived
yeah okay and you and he was embraced by
the American public hmm they loved him
now if you cannot find more of a
quintessential spirits have an angry
young angry black man than George
Foreman he knocked everyone out flat he
hurt them right he was mean and you know
why Americans embraced him all he did
was he went out and when he won he to
set a little American flag and you know
who excoriated him and who rejected him
with the black community they called him
an Uncle Tom you can go read interviews
from George Foreman where he said you
know what he said I never thought it was
a political statement to wave a flag
said and never received more hate in my
life then from the black community
calling me and Uncle Tom and I say that
because I think it's important they're
rewriting history now as though people
were mad because these guys were black
and if you read interviews with these
men that's exactly what they were
actually quite racist
yeah George Foreman was the beloved
athlete and also Joe Frazier circo's
Muhammad Ali Olympics Joe Frazier George
Foreman and they were all embraced by
white America I think this idea that
America white Americans have always
despised black Americans is often
rewritten yeah nursing okay I mean it's
hard for me to comment on that since
I've never read about this situation
okay we can bring it closer to home how
do you feel about the collar capital
situation canoeing through yeah I don't
think I'm not a fan but I also don't
watch football
I don't watch football so but for me I
think that people can vote with their
dollar and my issue with that is not
someone kneeling
happen what do you mean I mean he got
fired but he's also not a very good
athlete come on it's not that it's not
the best and the truth is if you're the
best you can get away with a full line
right yeah I mean look at my kids that
have to be the way it is you have to be
the very best you get away I think it
should be performing to my face and I
know well I don't think it's freedom of
speech if you're doing it when you're
being spread out it's an expression what
freedom of expression is not a right
form of speech is nothing that's
important for people to note because
right now a lot of people are setting
for new the expressions they vandalize
other people's businesses right that's
not a constitutional right but freedom
of speech is now you have the right to
say whatever you want you don't have the
right to express yourself however you
want especially when you're at a job so
other words imagine if you walked into
in and out and they said hey we need
what do you do it in and out
do it all you do it all yeah I think it
was just I would walk with a scarlet and
so if they go hey oh jeez hey you got
those calluses you do lift weights so
you go in and out and say hey we need to
get those where's the double-doubles
animal-style going in the ultra No
and you start kneeling they say you know
what you've been showing up late and not
doing that well we're gonna axe you and
you go no I'm kneeling you're not doing
your job and keep in mind these are
athletes were paid to do a job and so I
think again that's all I like in the
middle of the game he stopped playing
his position to me that's not what was
happening well he decided to make it
performance art while they're in the
national yeah that's something that is a
typical obviously it was a statement he
was clear as to what a statement was and
Americans most Americans said well we
don't want to be paying an athlete I
think it's hard to say most Americans
most Americans a portion of Americans I
mean it's always hard to say most you
know you cannot fly with statistics you
can but the statistics were overwhelming
most Americans sided with disrespect
most I'd like to read more deeply into
it okay why what they meant that's
really that they pulled and well here's
what I will say about common camera yeah
I don't like kneeling for the flag
I won't kneel for any person ever as a
Christian we're called not to kneel to
any human being I only kneel when I pray
okay anyone who tries to re-appropriate
that into a racial thing I think is
trying to
they're trying to exert authority that
they have not been given so that's me I
don't kneel for anything and I would
never ask you to kneel and thank God
that we have a country with a flag that
is literally based on the promise that
none of us will have to kneel for
another that's a good thing too now if
he wants to kneel in the middle the park
where no one is around so his expression
doesn't mean much no no if he wants to
kneel and his coaches are okay with a
mister hey you know what Neil we support
it I thought they were capable and if
they are okay with it and the American
public is okay with it and they don't
lose advertising dollars then he can
kneel
why should the American public have to
be okay with it they don't have to be
okay with it yeah maybe that so they let
they let Colin Kapernick Joel because
they didn't want to lose revenue because
Americans voted with their dollar I
think they have that that's an actual
right that you have to spend your money
as you see fit I think it's very hard to
say that Colin Kapernick kneeling was
the isolated event that led to them I
don't honey that year I don't there was
a sheet or a huge boycotts yeah huge
boycotts and the team didn't want to
deal with that controversy just like
right now there's a you may know this
there's a player someone might notice
who refuses to play because one of the
coaches was seen wearing in one American
news t-shirt he just said I saw the
headline yeah I'm read it a player has
that right yeah you know if he says hey
I don't want to play for a guy who has
this opinion he has that right and the
coach who wears the shirt has the right
to say okay hit the bricks or I won't
wear the shirt all right so let me ask
you this do you think it's a reasonable
position like if Colin Kaepernick wants
to kneel and the coaches and the league
have no problem with it and they keep
him and the league wants to let the
cards fall where they may financially I
say let him do it
I think the league should have let him
do it why do you think I want a shoe so
so many people why do you think it is an
issue for him not to kneel for what he
sees as a I hate the simple because I
think it's a very ignorant politically
uneducated statement because again no
one has done more for I want to say
black not only black Americans but
blacks across the globe in the United
America and I think that every single
nickel I don't think every single nation
in the world
has practiced slavery the United States
is singularly unique in that we fought
when the bloodiest Wars of all time to
end it we fought one of the bloodiest
Wars 2 key fish we fought our nation
yeah we did would anybody say Africa end
it would you know have any idea how many
sleeves are on the there's a lot but
also I think what about guitar my point
is we want to talk about civil rights
violations it's not a flag where you
have had millions of black Americans who
have died and are proud to have that
flag erected so that they have to kneel
before it I feel like right now you're
using a what about ISM just because
there are other issues with other
nations doesn't mean that we can't
recognize the issues that persist in our
nation so what issues that's my question
he's kneeling for what what is she she's
kneeling for issues like police
brutality all right generally that
brings us full circle yeah so do you
believe that there is a systemic problem
of police brutality against black
Americans item I think there is a
systemic problem with classism which
ties into racism because many black
people are poor okay so you believe
police are more likely to shoot someone
poor regardless of race I um possibly
because of over policing there are more
police so if we say that the state every
police officer has the same statistical
chance to shoot somebody and there are
more police in one area for a certain
amount people I think it's more likely
that those people are gonna be shot okay
so you don't think it's a race thing
because Colin Cowie does um and that was
the reason he was kneeling I don't think
you need to say that is isolated as a
race issue but once again often times
you need to when you talk about racism
you talk about classes and you need to
keep in mind how intertwined the two are
okay and I don't think it's fair to try
to isolate and say well this is an issue
because I'm sorry I'm annoyed
Excalibur's I don't think you're in
angry black man it's okay but let me I
guess you mentioned police brutality
because Colin Kaepernick kneeled for
police brutality right specifically this
goes back to Mike Brown well it was a
lot his hands were not don't shoot he
was punching a cop repeated in the face
and tried to take his gun sure so can
you see how when someone kneels based on
a lie the hands up don't shoot which
never happened and you have other
Americans who support police officers
including black Americans by the way
there's a higher portion of black police
officers then there are a percentage of
black Americans and they go his hands
were not don't shoot he was violently
assaulting an officer Darren Wilson who
by the way asked to be in an area so
that he could help assist the black
community and communicate them look more
effectively and this is a lie people get
upset with that now I do think we have a
police problem we have a police reform
problem and I think we agreed one of the
ways to reform unions I think we need
better training but the island Kapernick
was kneeling and if you look at some of
his speeches after that in interviews
that he gave because he believed that
black people were basically basically
being modern-day lynched by police and
that's what these riots are in Dallas
yeah I don't agree with that I don't
think it's true do you think that's the
case I think there's an element of truth
to it um you know there's so many things
where like I as a working person with
obligations I don't have the time to go
and read every single article but when I
do see you headlines I feel like there
is an overwhelming amount of odd events
that occur of like literal modern-day
lynchings we're going like actual black
people literally being lynched okay I I
don't know how to further describe it
this like the verb - I think we need
some specific examples we all agreed
George Floyd was horrible and the guy
deserved to be charged with Manson
what's what's her name Brianna Taylor
the cops showed up to her place and
there was there's like four or five cops
and they killed her and they haven't
been charged yet wait run Oh Taylor I
took you know yeah sorry I thought you
were doing Shana porn gains and then
there was there's a lot on the hammer
Giger okay
ever again give up okay boss and Jon and
then losing it sorry see there's so many
I'm on Aubrey I'm Aubrey there's so many
okay so what I believe that was a modern
day lynching that's actually a good
example because we just talked about
that one now I could if you would like
to I would like to get into some of the
statistics which I think are important
because I think both black and white
Americans should know them rather than
just headlines yeah but a Matar burry is
very interesting to me because the men
who shot yeah right that was they
weren't cops I thought one of them was
an ex-police who's next please yeah but
they called the cops
yeah typically when you're about to
commit a hate crime you don't call the
cops and if you look there was a
struggle for the firearm a struggle for
the gun with a Marberry right the man
literally was jogging down the street
and then two armed men tried to ensure
and I think with any rational person
would have tried to disarm them in that
tub you see I don't have you seen him on
our breeze interaction with police
officers outside of that matters yeah
what if I were to tell you that he was
an incredibly violent unruly and
threatening man literally even said to
the cops he was driving on a suspended
license through his parked next to a
railway track I could show you this
video right now
the police officer came up and very
nicely asked him for his identification
he told me who's gonna come up then came
up on the police officer shoved him
reach his hand in his pockets was given
three or four warnings with these police
officers they never even shot him or
tased him they let him go with a
suspended license illegally parked
threatening an officer without so much
as a warning so don't think that
interaction gives the two men that
murdered him the right to murdered him
no I don't think gives the right to
murder that but the idea again we don't
really have the sound do it if you look
at it we have a man with a gun aimed at
the floor and we have another man who
claims he was jogging we know that
wasn't the case he was very far from his
house and we have him reach out and grab
the gun you know I don't think that's a
lynching a lynching is literally an
entire town of people hanging somebody
because they're black I don't know if
that's the Zion tired town that the
definition should be a public a public
execution it would be a public execution
that's condoned by the public okay and
that doesn't that doesn't seem to be the
case there it's of an unfortunate
situation but I think if we're gonna
look for a lynching we need a more
clear-cut example
racecard Brooke that was raised as an
example okay like I said earlier any
wintry hmm I haven't seen any modern
winter I haven't heard has data
interactions we used as a luncheon like
that have any heard anyone refer to it
as a winter yeah I think I don't think I
talked about this I'm not sure I think
it is right
I don't listener and I don't think you
should ever take your gun out unless you
intend to use it that's to protect
yourself right I think those men were
wrong but I think if you're concerned
cuz they're robberies in an area and you
have a guy like a motto Bree again if
you understand the history there how he
was acting them calling the cops saying
hey we think this guy might be a burglar
I think that's an enforcement situation
where they deserve to be charged
accordingly but I don't think it's a
lynching I never said that it was a
lynching oh I was asking for examples of
modern a lynchings you said you see some
that look like lynchings and you
mentioned oh I forget more friend two
headlines of Elections that are very
light okay come here prepared yeah I
know it's really a cop-out when people
say that but no no no I mean that's have
been the most productive conversation
all day um I do think it matters because
there's this narrative out there that
you know black people are being shot in
record numbers well I mean that the fact
is that's not true if an unarmed white
man is far more likely to be shot by an
officer an unarmed black
there are a lot more white men and I
mean a percentage really yeah as a
percentage last year there were nine
unarmed black men shot by cops there
were 19 white guys now you could say
well blacks only make up ten to fifty
percent of the population so this is one
of those games where we can toy the
numbers and say no it's not even close
young black men are actually 36 times
more likely to commit homicide they
commit 50% of homicides 60% of violent
robberies in this country when you look
at the actual interactions with officers
significantly higher and their shot
significantly less when unarmed even
more importantly so you keep saying
unarmed this is where I was going or we
can play with the numbers okay how many
times are weapons being reported on
white men things like that you know I
think it's hard to say I think it's one
of those situations where you can point
to your numbers I can point to my
numbers but like we have to look at the
reality of like what happens to people
and I can only speak on my lived
experience with my black friends first
my white friends versus myself well
that's anecdotal and I think yeah sure
you know people say that statistics are
just groups of anecdotes right know at
people that I know people say that when
they don't like statistics that are
overwhelming again that would be the
case for talking about one police
precinct this includes all police data
that we have the FBI the DOJ a lot of
these enterprises obviously a lot of
these wings of government a lot of these
police departments are headed up by
black people and black mayors and black
stakes an officer of the law is 18 times
more likely eighteen and a half times
more likely to be shot by a black man
than a black man is by a police officer
there's no way you can tweak those
numbers because we have mortality rates
18 times more likely a cop is shot by a
black man a black gun shot by a cop and
so I think right now and I think both
are very valid issues that we should
think of it right but do you think we're
making it worse the riots and the idea
of framing it through race which I
believe is false I think right now I'm
very good let me tell you this I'm very
concerned really no no I seriously I was
talking with someone at YouTube about
this yeah I think that right now you're
going to see more racists whenever in
the history of United States I grew up
in a post-racial America largely yeah
you see the riots and eluding and yet a
lot of young people who unfortunately
when the media says race race race black
lives matter and you see riots and
hundreds of millions of dollars for
billions of dollars in property damage
to my 25 million just in the city of
Minneapolis alone when you have police
were leaving the force because they're
being shot and paralyzed in record
numbers over 25 people dead over 400
officers shot I think and when the
meeting goes black black black black
you're gonna have a lot of young white
kids who would have never grown up with
this condition and go I guess this is
black and that really concerns me that's
a big part of what I'm out here and I
hope that you understand that you
believe me when I say that does come
from an authentic place it's a
legitimate concern of mine I never said
that I thought the riots or a good thing
right I'm largely agree with you yeah
and I think that it is get to get
education out there and then spread the
word on what you think issues are but I
think another large issue with black
America is that we don't mobilize our
voters very well how do you mean when
you look at the data on people who are
going out to vote like as a whole in
America and
we have a very low voter turnout that's
right that's a very big issue because I
think the people who do go and vote
oftentimes are not concerned about the
lower-class issues when you look a lot
of people who are voting are wealthier
so they're voting for things that
pertain to them and we need to summon we
need to get education out there or to
lower class neighborhoods and ankles on
why they do need to vote and then now
why do you think lower class white
people vote and black and why do you
think poor white people vote since you
mentioned classism and black people in
poverty don't might all tie back into
the history of the country I I don't I
don't have a definite I don't have an
answer either I'm wondering why that is
because no you mention classes yeah
inkling on why I might be honest it I
couldn't give you an answer yeah I
really couldn't give you an answer as to
why you know because often a lot of
Trump voters are crap they're like well
they're just a bunch of hits you know I
mean there's a cuz the Republican Party
went from the party of the rich to now
it's the party of dumb uneducated white
guys like okay why do uneducated you
know white guys who make less money and
white women why do they get out and vote
and then black people in the same income
bracket don't vote as much I don't it's
that I thought sort populism I don't
know because it's not just with Donald
Trump they get out and vote regardless
and it's always as a matter of fact
we've seen more voter turnout for black
Americans obviously with Barack Obama
and with Donald Trump you know Donald
Trump has more percent higher percentage
of the black vote than any Republican I
think in modern history
I don't know I'm always curious as to
what the answer is I know there are a
lot of people who try to get to the
mobilizing vote including a lot of black
conservatives a lot of black Republicans
or pro-life activists I think maybe this
is this is just an opinion
okay I can't substantiate this I think
the black vote is taken for granted by
the Democratic Party
and I think they don't really feel that
they need to earn it so for example I
think Joe Biden is a good example when
it goes on and says if you don't vote
for me y'all ain't black I think that's
an example that was painful did I have
watched that interview before like it
made headlines because decent up until
the end I mean for Parkinson's yeah okay
with most acknowledge a lower stance it
was acceptable and then said well do you
think that my painful so when he says
that that assumes that for example could
you imagine I think we both agree if
Donald Trump said that people like oh my
god if he said if you know those would
be you that black feel like what the but
when Joe Biden says it I think he feels
comfortable saying that because he takes
the blame there's a lot of backlash for
that it definitely wasn't a lot of
background right but I don't think you'd
ever see Republicans say that to that
extent he's saying if you don't vote
quite literally if you don't vote for me
you're not black that's him basically
saying all black people have to vote
Democrat and so again this is an opinion
I think it's taken for granted by the
Democratic Party and so they don't
really speak to them a lot beyond
promising free stuff you know I mean
they don't really speak to a lot of the
issues like we've spoke we've swing
about buddy fee issues that affect the
black community for example we've talked
about education I think that's one of
the most productive conversations we've
had reset it's not a money problem
it's an allocation problem it's a
training problem it's a reform of the
system and the unions which we agreed on
right yeah no democratic candidate is
saying they're saying listen if you go
for me we'll put more money in your
school district yeah because free stuff
is very appealing for people who are
only looking at it surface level yeah
and I think I think that's across the
board both white and black people I
think is a problem that a lot of the
times the candidates appeal to let you
said surface level free stuff and I
think unfortunately happens with the
DIMM I believe it happens the Democratic
Party particularly Joe Biden or Hillary
Clinton and black voters quite a bit I
think they're taken for granted and I
don't think you're one of them
I don't think you're one of them I think
people like you can
and by people like you I mean sharp
young yes black men can hold people like
that accountable cuz it'll take people
like you
it'll take people like you who think
critically it'll take people like you
who sit down and have a conversation and
neither one of us get mad I think that
it only changes from guys or Z's like
yourself I really enjoyed the
conversation
oh it's been fun you don't see seem mad
obviously I have rdf:li you know I went
to couples therapy and literally my
there's like yeah she looks pissed my
favorite just call it RBF don't think
she's mad at you she just has my wife
has the worst RBF it's a struggle
struggle we have a powerful power fist
for our bf policy yeah well stop
discriminating against of RBF please
hi well thank you man I appreciate it so
it was I forgot your name again it was a
whole Kendall Cole Kendall hope my
Twitter all right Thank You Kendall
calls your Twitter I really appreciate
it man hopefully we talk some other time
I think it's great thank you all right
god bless hey there YouTube you if you
liked this installment I've changed my
mind click on one of these other
installments playing in a box it's the
only way you can find it because if you
search it it may not show up because
it's controversial and in YouTube wants
to UM discourage that the controversy to
change my mind playing by the rules we
just don't know what they are
subscribing to notifications